et madame auriez vous une pirate traîner
dans les rues dernièrement où quelqu'un
qui me ressemblaient mais hambourg et
nous envoient tranquille vous êtes folle
où tout le monde veut dire un truc du
genre depuis ce matin
il
[Musique]
et c'est ça c'est là qu'elle allait
d'après la prof je sens qu'elle est
toute proche
j'en suis sûr bonjour je cherche une
pirate et moi cherchons sens de la vie
vous n'avez pas plus précis comme
demande
d'habitude les gens me demandent à voir
ou juste un paquet de clopes j'ai pas
soif
mais j'ai un portrait automates si vous
voulez c'est une caméra cachée c'est ça
ok je me débrouillais sans vous c'est
pas le seul bar au monde ok espèce de
personnes négatives on lâche rien on
lâche rien mademoiselle on peut discuter
vous êtes une pirate avant mais je
représente l'association le retour du
roi
avez-vous déjà rêvé d'un retour de la
monarchie en france l'association le
retour du roi milite pour établir une
vraie monarchie de droit divin en france
afin d'aider tous ces français en perte
de repères depuis si longtemps et si ça
vous intéresse n'hésitez pas à aller sur
le site pour nous faire un don comme ça
on pourra peut-être acheter un autre os
d'une couronne
j'étais comme toi avant ouvre les yeux
donc bonjour je cherche un troll aux jo
je ne sais pas je pense pas d'alcool
excusez moi
alors voilà ça va vous paraître bizarre
mais je cherche une femme qui me
ressemble et qui s'habille en pirate
mais qui n'est pas moi et il est
possible que vous l'ayez croisé ivre
dans un bar non pas que je présume que
vous passez vous même votre temps en
vivre dans des bars mais sait-on jamais
enfin vous l'avez vu ouais j'aurais du
mal à l'oublier
elle passait du supplice de la planche
ces deux jours le truc où on vous jette
à l'eau alors en théorie oui mais là il
n'y avait pas d'eau elle magistrat paix
avec une plainte mais ouais elle était
beau et c'est parfait où est ce que je
peut la trouver au tennessee
merci merci merci merci lucrecia je sais
où la pirate se cache
[Musique]